my second story is about love and loss I
was lucky I found what I loved to do
early in life woz and I started Apple in
my parent's garage when I was 20 we
worked hard and in 10 years Apple had
grown from just the two of us in a
garage into a two billion dollar company
with over 4,000 employees we just
released our finest creation the
Macintosh a year earlier and I just
turned 30 and then I got fired how can
you get fired from a company you started
well as Apple grew we hired someone who
I thought was very talented to run the
company with me and for the first year
or so things went well but then our
visions of the future began to diverge
and eventually we had a falling out when
we did our Board of Directors sided with
him and so at 30 I was out and very
publicly out what had been the focus of
my entire adult life was gone and it was
devastating I really didn't know what to
do for a few months I felt that I had
let the previous generation of
entrepreneurs down that I had dropped
the baton as it was being passed to me I
met with David Packard and Bob Noyce and
tried to apologize for screwing up so
badly I was a very public failure and I
even thought about running away from the
valley but something slowly began to
dawn on me I still loved what I did the
turn of events at Apple had not changed
that one bit I've been rejected but I
was still in love and so I decided to
start over I didn't see it then but it
turned out that getting fired from Apple
was the best thing that could have ever
happened to me
the heaviness of being successful was
replaced by the lightness of being a
beginner again less sure about
everything it freed me to enter one of
the most creative periods of my life
during the next five years I started a
company named next another company named
Pixar and fell in love with an amazing
woman who would become my wife
Pixar went on to create the world's
first computer animated feature film Toy
Story and is now the most successful
animation studio in the world
in a remarkable turn of events Apple
bought next and I returned to Apple and
the technology we developed it next is
at the heart of Apple's current
Renaissance and Laureen and I have a
wonderful family together I'm pretty
sure none of this would have happened if
I hadn't been fired from Apple
it was awful tasting medicine but I
guess the patient needed it sometime
life sometimes life's gonna hit you in
the head with a brick don't lose faith
I'm convinced that the only thing that
kept me going was that I loved what I
did you've got to find what you love and
that is this true for work as it is for
your lovers your work is going to fill a
large part of your life and the only way
to be truly satisfied is to do what you
believe is great work and the only way
to do great work is to love what you do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
and don't settle as with all matters of
the heart you'll know when you find it
and like any great relationship it just
gets better and better as the years roll
on so keep looking don't settle